[Music]
Google smorgas corta and tell me what
you think it is
I mean it's a cake but it has shrimps
and salmon and the base is bread so it's
a sandwich cake it's it's like smurger's
daughter
you can't really describe in in the
other way
[Music]
I do love a food that defies
expectations and this one does seem to
have it all it's a Swedish classic from
the 1930s this is
I'm the owner and the head pastry chef
here they've got them he says that it's
a very Swedish food if you're from Outer
Sweden you think meatballs is so Swedish
but it's not it's Mother's thought is
very typical Swedish you have it all
over the country
so for the record what is it
okay daughter and it's sandwich
so it's a sandwich cake but like
logistically the base of this sandwich
cake is a white bread that has a filling
we have a special mixture called skog
Andrea here it's just fresh shrimps
mayonnaise and a pinch of a horseradish
the cake is then covered in a whip
cooked cream cheese and or mayonnaise
and left to sit refrigerated overnight
and then we decorated with the salads
and shrimps
a lot of people love it we make at least
10 a day
so I mean it's a big big
[Music]
surprisingly here in New York City I was
unable to find it yeah hi I was
wondering if you guys had smorgas torta
you don't
okay thank you yeah I was wondering if
you guys had smorgas torta
you don't you don't okay thank you
so I'm gonna just have to make it on my
own
we usually have two different kinds we
have one with meat and then we have with
the seafood so I'm gonna go with the
seafood one there's a really big Seafood
section here at my grocery store it
comes from Smorgasbord a full Buffet
filled with Delicacies
hello
[Music]
my grandma always used to serve smokers
thought that when I was a kid it's part
of our inheritage here because it's the
best of everything
[Music]
I've got what I need for part one Joven
Chef walk me through this if you don't
want to cook it's perfect dish first we
cut the bread then we spread the filling
mini shrimp salads then put another
layer of bread this is not a typical
activity for me to do on my living room
floor another filling and then the bread
it looks like buttercream truly
[Music]
that we covered in fresh cheese or
mayonnaise part one done off to the
fridge
day two day after you decorate it with
all the fresh fish and the salmon little
shrimps and everything and then you eat
the same day so it gets quite creamy and
quite to say do we there's a lot of
flavors but it's not a lot of texture
[Music]
all right let's see what this is
oh I think you even did this a bit of an
injustice I think the word gooey is not
right I do feel that it's very soft but
like
if you like cream cheese and if you like
smoked fish make yourself a smorgas
towards up it's uh it's good I wonder if
you used maybe a heartier bread actually
who cares this is good
my final verdict on this is it a
sandwich or a cake yovan's right it's
just a sandwich cake I'm curious let me
know in the comments if there are any
other Foods you'd like to learn about
and have me explore until then
School
[Music]
our store is Live use the link in the
caption to grab your great big story
merch and don't forget to like subscribe
and leave a comment